I like to think of intents as envelopes,
each one who includes who,
or in this case, which component
you want it delivered to.
And there's room for a small amount
of data to be delivered,
packaged as extras.
Primitive tuples that will be
available to the application component
that ultimately receives
and opens this intent.
An explicit intent explicitly specifies
the name of the recipient,
as you can see on this envelope.
Implicit intents are a lot
more interesting.
Here, we don't specify
the name of the class.
We don't even know what it is.
So, how do we indicate
which activity to launch?
You know those stories you
sometimes hear about letters
with fake addresses like these
that somehow still find
their way to the recipient?
Well the intent resolution system
on Android works the same way,
finding an activity
capable of performing the action
you specify on the associated data.
So, rather than specifying
the name of a class, you indicate
an action you'd like
an activity to perform,
and on what data that action
should be performed.
Like this, where we want
to address an activity
that's capable of viewing a website.
And because intents can cross
through application boundaries,
the activity that started
may not be part of your app.
So, you can include functionality
like this, browsing websites
or making phone calls
or choosing a contact
from your address book,
all from within your app,
without you having to implement
any of it yourself.
You don't even need
to know about the app
that will ultimately service your request.
You can find details
of some of the intents
supported by native apps
in Common Intents page
of the Android developer site.